foreign
[Music]
I'm your captain Ryan Clark how are you
doing no how are you doing no how are
you doing you tell me you told me you
tell me [ __ ]
[Music]
this may be the worst disaster since
Google folded they'll figure this out
you know they turn the moon into a
massive jail they patented the liquid
glove how hard could it be to reset a
course
crew karaoke tonight Captain I only ever
sing when I'm drunk so ask me again at 5
PM who got it
foreign
I am not fake I am I am solid I'm
Dependable I am unfucking flappable
morning man new dawn has broken so has
our toilet we're not animals you know
right I will talk to Matt about that
good luck pissing in the basement in the
next three years
[Music]
you're a damn hero yeah you were a hero
then be a hero now the captain so yeah
imagine with you people it was the
paramedics I've said this over and over
again the fire on Avenue 3 was put out
by firefighters and the sprinklers came
down from the ceiling I was a bystander
I can be in the vicinity of a
catastrophe wearing a nice hat anything
more than that I'm out
[Music]
please just let me fix your door no I'm
gonna do this myself I may be a fake at
a fraud and a terrible lay and a credit
risk and a tax Dodger and an emotional
homunculus but I am still a useful
functioning
as you can you do this
[Music]
morning
sorry it took me so long to realize that
you existed no problem
so popcorn and dirty jugs who's in so
she said wait a minute but who was that
on the ladder
Mr Harris Ames Captain Ryan Clark well
that's quite a grip you go there Captain
well I treat handshakes the way I treat
my job I like pressure oh yeah so
pressure creates diamonds and consider
this a 25 carat Shake I like it I I also
have manly hands correct Iris
Ellie like shovels tell them about my
firm grip did you guys hear about my
drip what I have a problem
I don't know what I'm doing I don't know
how anybody knows what they're doing
does anybody know what they're doing how
does everything work does anybody know
how I mean who knows how that door works
it doesn't work
[Music]
[Applause]
calm and I cannot stress this enough the
[ __ ] down
[Music]